I'll be promoting this movie I'll be
promoting this movie until it goes to a
streamer I'll be promoting it uh
shamelessly I'm proud of it I I had a
great time shooting it it's in theaters
it'll be on video on demand it'll be on
the streamer I'm sure I don't know but
I'm sure
I'm promoting fully loaded My Summer
Festival with 19 different Comics I'm
promoting the top soft World Tour that
starts again this fall I'm promoting my
cruise the fully loaded Cruise I'm
promoting Red Rocks I'm promoting so
many things
that today was the very first time in my
career
where I said in January I'm gonna take a
break I'm going to take a break and go
like
hey man let's let's get your resting
heart rate down yeah let's let's get
some sleep
let's let's maybe take off like three
months from drinking like that's just
really like slow it down and and also
not think when you're thinking in promo
all the time
it can be a little exhaust I mean you
think you think it's exhausting look at
my feed it's exhausting to be my feed
I'm my feed
that's that's less is more
but one of the things that nope
one of the things that inspires me about
Rogan for example
is uh
he almost never does this kind of stuff
yeah yeah in the House suddenly does
this podcast because you're right less
is more how what does he do it like once
a month yeah no he does it three times a
[__] week yeah
more is more is perfect but for example
when he does like a story or something
like this he does one take
it's kind of shitty it's the same day
it's the same it's elk with a bunch of
jalapenos a knife that he had sent to
him by a [__] knife maker and him
going look at this look at this Traeger
smoker I reverse seared this this is
what's great look at this I'm about to
put in the butter and like this is
grass-fed butter this elk really raises
my testosterone Rogan is it's you're
right with guys like Rogan when he does
do a story if they're a little precious
yeah and there's I don't think he's he's
ever done a second take any of those
stories no unless you have to really
admire that like uh if the shot is
framed poorly if the audio sucks doesn't
matter do you remember when he this is
like like I can get in the Weeds on
Rogan but and especially when it's
Instagram do you remember when he got
his Polar Plunge and he couldn't sit in
a minute and then the next day and then
he must have gotten it on the internet
bad yeah he must have gotten it bad yeah
the next day he sat in for 20 minutes
and he lowered his core temperature by
like two degrees and it took him like a
month to get that back yeah that is that
[__] man what an interesting you know
what I told you at the beginning we were
just talking
I like I really enjoy I draw inspiration
for men I'm not like
um
you David Goggins cam Haynes
um Andrew heberman huberman I love uh uh
uh [__] I mean there's so many guys
like that Rogan you know Tim Kennedy
like there are a lot of guys that are
like just very different men than me and
I love Jocko willnick like I love
I love reading their stuff or listening
to their audiobooks or what listen to
their podcast because I'm so not like
that but that for me when I add a little
bit of that in my life like I remember
you one I don't know what you were doing
but you were walking us through your day
and it was so
fascinating
it was like it was like I ran eight
miles today I listened to an audiobook I
was running eight miles and then I came
and I worked for about three hours
straight on AI stuff and I'm like and I
was like wait you sat at a desk like you
like sat at a desk and like and I I
actually
I wouldn't even know what to do I would
start doing crafts like I would like to
that you went I was like is your
computer like yeah have you sat for like
four hours
focused on a single task me yeah no no
oh I have a hard time sleeping for four
hours yeah like I I don't have that
I I don't have a brain that like I
really admired it when I listened to you
do it because then you were like you're
taught you were fasting at the time
you're doing your fast and then you talk
about what you ate and I was jealous I
wanted to be able to be like that and I
think at that time we started I think
you're doing maybe bone broth or
something and we started doing bone
broth
pretty religiously and adding that into
a fast because I was like
it does for someone like me it does feel
cool to add a little bit of control into
life so integrating a little bit of a
way of being from another person that
you're not like yeah like like uh like
so so David Goggins is consistently
pushing himself
I love I did it I did it over the
pandemic more but I loved going today
I'm running a marathon I'm gonna get on
the treadmill and it's not it's not
gonna be all at once but I'm gonna get
through a Marathon today so let's get up
get this text from coffee and let's see
if we can do like five miles and then
know that we started there and that was
really fun because like
um cam Haines does that too where he
goes like
he almost just sets the limit and then
and then achieves that his son Truitt is
really fascinating because it's untrue
it's right now is trying to get the and
like I bet people would never think that
this is who I watch but I get real
inspiration from those people because I
showed Jocko I showed a clipped to Jocko
to Isla because Isla's like me like like
a a person of her fluids impulse
I walked in on her one time she was in
the pantry in a bathrobe in the dark
drinking a root beer yeah and I opened
the door and she went I said what she
goes I thought you were mom shut the
door and I shut the door to let her
finish the root beer yes she has a hard
time waking up so Isla come in here I
want you to see this clip from Jocko she
goes who's Jocko I said he's a Navy SEAL
she goes he works at the zoo I went no
it's a Navy [__] seal I go it's a
badass job she goes it's a silly name
and I went no it's not it isn't a silly
name these guys are the toughest dudes
in the world she goes she's kind of
right though about the silly name I
never even realized that oh yeah you
talk to a child yeah and so I go watch
this what he says about waking up so it
hits the thing and Joker Goes
first thing you do when you hear that
alarm clock
you could roll over you could go back to
bed you could hit snooze but you get out
of bed and that's your first Victory and
Isla has paused and she goes
how great is that nap right after you
hit snooze though it is pretty funny
you're missing the point yeah this whole
speech he's with Casey neistat when he's
telling this speech he's with Casey
neistat and uh so I hit it and then he
goes and then you've got a victory under
your belt then you go to the gym and you
work out like are you listening to this
island she goes yeah and he goes then
when you go to the work now you've got
two victories you've worked out and
you've woken up on time you didn't hit
that snooze button so when you go into
that break room and you see donuts and
she hits the balls she goes
um if he's about to say no to Donuts I'm
done listening I was definitely gonna
say no to Donuts do you think he's gonna
have a donut and she goes
you like this guy I go I [__] love
him and she goes do you think he'd like
you and I go what do you mean she goes
dad you hit snooze you skip working out
and you love donuts and I'm like yeah
you're making a good [__] point I go
I but I but I do love that like I love
to watch that brain work and go like
like I don't I don't hit snooze like I
don't hit snooze now I go [__] it
because I'm up but I and then and then I
go to the gym every single morning I go
to the gym every single morning and
today is National Donut Day I didn't
have a donut
and so like I I like I try I like try to
apply these a little bit because I mean
the other side of me is like tonight
after we do this
I'll do another podcast and then I'm
gonna call Leanne and go yo we're in
Beverly Hills meet me out here let's go
have drinks let's go have [__] couple
Campari Spritz
all right let's go over her friend's
house and overnight let's get some
edibles and let's [__] have a night
about it get some sushi go have sex in
the hot tub and I gotta work out at
[__] 10 in the morning
I gotta tell you that nap let me press
news is the sweetest
that's that's my victory first Victory
is pressing snooze and getting a nap
onto the Belt have you ever had I had so
this this morning I didn't work I didn't
work out I'd press at like five in the
morning until about six you're going
hard right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
flew to Austin I was like what
yeah what just run around theaters and
now you're back yeah running around
theaters to do to promote the movie and
then look you only get one shot at these
movies so you might as well and look
it's really hard to get people to go
into a movie theater right now and so
I woke up at like six to five or six to
seven did press
and then I went and I said and I'm
really into a podcast uh History Podcast
right now and I was listening to this
one about the Conquistadors and I was
and I was like before when I woke up I
was like I wouldn't mind going back to
that and I said I'll tell you what
I'm gonna take a little nap
and go now I slept good last night I
slept like seven hours last night
boy that 30 minute nap it felt like five
hours and I woke up going
I gotta readjust my sleep score that has
to be in the 97 that's the best [__]
nap those little snooze naps are
monsters